foreign
[Applause]
like most of us you've probably asked
yourself at some point
why is it that they stuff pro players
into these glass boxes at big events
well aside from looking pretty badass
they were actually originally designed
for one specific purpose to eliminate
sound coming from the fans and casters
in case it gave the players on stage an
edge you see in traditional sports this
isn't really a problem hearing the
screams of thousands of fans can be
motivating but there's no real unfair
advantage to be gained but in esports
we've seen countless cases over the
years where players have benefited from
hearing crowd noise on land
what is he my goodness how interesting
zip x
through underpass he's got glaive in tow
as well now do these booths actually
work as intended like do they block out
sound entirely or do they kind of just
muffle things and with noise cancelling
technology becoming more and more
advanced is the answer to this problem
maybe just a decent pair of headphones
let us break down the complex history of
sound on land
and how it's actually affected some of
esports's biggest moments
okay so with the exception of maybe
tennis or golf nearly every athlete in
traditional sports can either benefit or
suffer from playing in front of
thousands of screaming fans so is sound
a problem that's unique only to esports
well regardless of what game you play
information always matters and since the
early days of esports we've been looking
for ways to preserve competitive
integrity and in certain games that
means shutting the crowd off from
players entirely which in most cases has
required getting a little bit creative
the question of course is
does any of this [ __ ] actually work or
is it all just for show well as mobas
and tactical shooters like dota league
of legends and counter-strike became
more and more popular they eventually
all faced the same issue dota in
particular added booths to the
international back in 2012 while league
of legends simply used noise-cancelling
headphones
although despite the change there were
still some kinks to work out for
this is level one okay so
as they're watching this and guys
it's a secret all right who's going to
scout this out i'm going to get scouted
like rtk's going to get scouted okay so
roshan's halfway through does he go
playboard level one how does this work
now
they have a good gail out and same thing
very global online they're going to kill
them
some games even decided to use earbuds
in conjunction with over ear headphones
the earbuds played the game audio while
the headphones played white noise to
help drown out the sound of the crowd
but over time they realized that sound
isn't the only problem after the 2016
nalcs summer split finals tsm's a.d
carey doublelift mentioned that he could
actually feel the vibration and rumble
of the fans cheering i actually think
the crowd is pretty super awesome
they're crazy crazy loud and energetic
and i could just kind of like feel the
energy and vibration
in the game but with 15 000 people in
attendance and no booths was it really
that surprising not long after that
shroud revealed that counter-strike
competitors faced a similar problem
you're playing it doesn't matter if
you're in a booth or not if you're
playing and you
you know you tap a couple of shots
through a smoke
and you hear the crowd kind of like they
just they'd have a giant o you know
and you hear it and you could hear you
could feel the vibration in the booth
and whatnot and you're like okay that
guy's in that smoke and you just spam
the [ __ ] out of the smoke and that's it
he's dead here's the biggest trick that
i feel people use the biggest trick that
people use at land so if you're
mid-round or something and you throw an
aid
and then you can hear the explosion you
know that someone's near that made
sure some of these fans were just trying
to have a good time and support their
teams but there have been instances like
at the esl pro league finals back in
2019
where the crowd has clearly tried to
give the home team an advantage just
checking for the little boost on the
spool so he was not ready for this
or is he my goodness how interesting zip
x
through underpass he has got glaive in
tow as well
and they get the frag unbelievable
astralis is there an alternate universe
where zip walks down that hallway and
gets killed without the predominantly
danish crowd signaling that there is an
opponent awaiting him
maybe but after the event he posted a
twit longer addressing competitive
integrity and counter-strike and in his
post he makes two pretty solid
suggestions of how we can fix this issue
now the first one is of course
booths
they've been used in various esports for
years now so there's really no excuse
not to use them at every event his
second suggestion was to reconsider the
placement of the speakers at these
events and to design the stage in a
manner that prevents players from
feeling the vibrations created by their
bassy grenades and molotovs but is that
really as easy as it sounds well dimitri
i suppose it depends on how much time
you've spent learning stage design and
audio engineering while massive esports
stages may be relatively new in the
grand scheme of things large stages with
complex speaker arrays are not and there
are two different types of noise
cancellation at work on these stages
passive and active passive noise
cancellation is anything you're using to
physically block sound like a booth or
those large padded ear muffs that look a
bit like headphones active noise
cancellation is a technique that
involves phase inversion now i'm not
going to bore you with too many
technical details
mostly because i'm not an audio engineer
but here's a quick explanation of how it
works you can find active noise
cancellation and tons of consumer
headsets these days the headset will use
a microphone to take in ambient sound
and then invert the waveform known as
phase inversion and feed that back into
your ears to cancel out the noise but
it's not just headphones you can
actually see this principle at work on a
stage as well if you ever notice some of
the speakers pointed backwards in a pa
stack they are likely sending out a
phase-inverted version of what the crowd
is hearing to cancel out that noise
backstage so that the crew can hear each
other talk without having to yell now i
know that's a lot of information but
don't worry as an esports fan all you
really need to worry about is showing up
and being loud but as someone who has
stood on a few main stages in his day i
love nerding out about stage design and
equipment set up for live esports events
and dimitri with all of your
esports clout i'm sure you've got plenty
of live esports event experience
right
what you mean sitting on the sidelines
and watching as other better gamers duke
it out on a main stage
i do actually
and let me tell you they uh they weren't
using controllers anyway the funniest
part about all of this is that back in
the mid 2000s one esport actually had
all of this figured out and it pains me
to say this because there are some of
you who are definitely way too young to
remember
but once upon a time
there was a game called starcraft brood
war brood war is without question the
single greatest esport of all time it's
not even a conversation don't believe me
cool doesn't matter you're just flat out
wrong how do i know that because in no
other esport has a competitor who sits
in a chair and sweats over a mouse and
keyboard for a living
entered the arena on a [ __ ]
full-blown commercial-sized
jet plane
[Applause]
now for those of you who were unlucky
enough not to behold the sheer
unadulterated splendor of brood war
let me give you a quick rundown of what
it was so starcraft brood war is an rts
or real strategy game released by
blizzard back in 1998. it was an
expansion for the original starcraft the
basic idea of the game is to collect
resources and upgrade your military
before conquering your opponents i
cannot [ __ ] believe that society has
degenerated to a point where i have to
explain what starcraft was
anyway the most important thing to note
is that starcraft was a game with fog of
war this means that each section of the
map remains hidden until you explore it
you don't have much information about
where your opponent is or what exactly
they're doing without having to look for
yourself now as starcraft grew in
popularity so too did its esports scene
and eventually thousands of fans would
show up to watch some of their favorite
players compete but even as early as the
early 2000s starcraft's stages
were pretty unique you see to avoid any
information being shared between the
players and the fans each player would
sit in their own glass booth armed with
headphones and white noise machines so
if someone did something clever in fog
of war the players couldn't hear the
crowd rumble
so this is the inside of a gone booth
right here
this is kind of cool i guess
yeah i've never been one of these before
yeah we know that
greg this is your first match so as we
take a step into these booths we can see
that not only are they given headphones
and earbuds to blast music in their ears
so they can only hear and think about
the game but we also have these lights
so the audiences can see them a little
better and even white noise generators
and everything is noise cancelling
including the headphones and the booth
so literally no sound escapes this when
the players end up starting that match
that is what it's focused time and that
is the only thing that they will be
thinking about so it's safe to say that
starcraft really had their [ __ ] together
they'd already solved esports's biggest
problem
but
as usual
the west had to show up
and [ __ ] everything up even today league
of legends has chosen to continue using
noise-cancelling headphones rather than
boots riot games recently announced a
partnership with bose which started with
worlds 2020 which means that their
headphones are now used at all global
riot events but although headphones
haven't really solved the crowd noise
problem in the past bose has made some
extraordinary strides over the past few
years when it comes to modern noise
cancellation technology the unfortunate
thing is that we haven't really been
able to test out how well they work for
the past year and a half or so because
well there's this thing called covet and
fans haven't really been filling arenas
as of late
which is a big sad but as the world
slowly returns back to normal and
competitions resume with supporters it
seems as though we might have more work
to do because it's pretty clear that we
haven't exactly found a proper solution
to this problem but the hope is that
we're close and who knows maybe once
we're able to test out bose's top of the
line headsets and we learn how to move
speakers around properly then perhaps
one day the battle against sound on lane
will be won but until then
it's hard to deny that korea's original
solution from the golden age of esports
is still the best they may not be
perfect but booths change the way we
think about sound in esports
forever
actually like i am an elitist but i'm
not an elitist towards controller
players like that's ridiculous right
like i'm gonna lead us towards these
[ __ ] league normies or [ __ ] valor
normies but like not [ __ ] controller
players like come on like if you're
bullying controller players you're
bullying like a child like that's just
not fun like it's just not even fair
all right
i'm not actually bullying you guys like
christ it's just collateral damage man
like it's just you know like i shot i
opt colton and it went through the
[ __ ] wall behind you and just hit you
like f we are controller players we are
one we are legion you should have one of
us yes
you shoot at all of us yeah